is there a a path towards reusability
for the second stage there is and we
know how to do that um right now I we're
going to work on manufacturing that
second stage to make it as inexpensive
as possible there sort of two paths for
a second stage make it
reusable um uh or work really hard to
make it inexpensive so you can afford to
expend it and th that trade
is actually not obvious which one is
better even in terms of cost even like
time even terms I'm talking about cost
is it you know space flight getting into
orbit is a solved problem we solved it
back in you know the 50s and 60s making
sound the only thing that the only
interesting problem is dramatically
reducing the cost of access to
orbit which is if you can do that you
open up a bunch of
new uh you know in Endeavors that lots
of startup companies everybody else can
do so that's we really that's our one of
our missions is to you know be part of
this industry and lower the cost to
orbit so that there can be you know a
kind of a Renaissance uh a golden age of
people doing all kinds of interesting
things in space I like how you said uh
getting to orbit is a solv problem it's
just the only interesting thing is
reducing the C you know you can describe
every single problem facing human
civilization that way the physicist
would say everything is a solved problem
we've solved everything the rest is just
uh with Rutherford said that it's just
stamp collecting it's just the detail
some of the greatest Innovations and
inventions and you know Brilliance is uh
in that cost reduction stage right and
you you've had a long career of cost
reduction for sure and if you know when
you what does cost reduction really mean
it means inventing a better way yeah
exactly right and when you invent a
better way you make the whole world
richer so you know whatever it was I
don't know how many thousands of years
ago somebody invented the plow and when
they invented the plow they made the
whole world richer because they made
farming less
expensive um and so it it is a big deal
to to invent better ways that's how the
world gets
richer
that